hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
know it's been a while I was busy with
packs but I've got something to show you
welcome to bubble bud Island I know it's
not much to see this kinda looks like a
dick pointing out to you but I built
this base not that this is the base
that's going on the island it's not the
island base that we're talking about
here this is the base that acts as a
precursor to the base that we are about
to build on this island now what took me
so long is that I needed a lot of
preparation time and that included
making this area for this staging ground
for the rest of the island that we're
about to build in this episode it's
happening now it's finally going down
god dammit sorry something I forgot
everything's fine
don't worry don't panic nothing's wrong
don't look around your house there is no
problem I was panicking for nothing so
I've got the list up here because I
forgot to get the list of people that
are going on the brand new lockers
because as you can see we've got a new
array which means that we need new names
here the first one goes to Stephanie
stump who was very concerned about my
dehydration Paul problem so thank you
very much Stephanie stump for enjoying
the series the next one goes to Emily
Cohen who just said they binge watch the
whole series so far and can't wait to
keep it up with real time and a chance
for her name on Locker which you
definitely get so I'm going to put
kou-kun however however you pronounce
that I have no idea but thank you so
much the next one to Coral Brown who
says who's very concerned about me
ramming things with the USS [ __ ] a duck
and I know for a fact that that little
submarine is designed to ram things with
its face words dick so anyway this is
going to Coral coral burn coral Brown
good enough for me the next one goes to
an Hayes who helped me name this island
and a lot of you guys out there we're
suggesting bubble blood island but she
said I really wish bubble butt was here
he was a very good helper and if you
remember bubble butt from soma
oh he's just a little a little delight I
loved bubble butt so much he was amazed
okay so the last one goes to Fonzie
braggin Fonzie Fonzie Bergen Fonzie
Bergen who said your fascination is
scrumptious mark I wish you good luck
with the curse of the emperor which if
I'm not mistaken there's going to be an
update real soon that adds the sea
dragon Leviathan which is separate from
the sea Emperor they're two different
entities but rumor has it that the sea
dragon Leviathan is actually the
creature that's going to be in those
abandoned lava pits or the the unused
lava flow there's gonna be two different
locations that are at in the near future
the lava caverns are gonna be finished
out the one that was in the last episode
and then there's gonna be a new place
was like a bone graveyard you're gonna
go down there and you're gonna see some
massive and I mean enormous skeletons of
creatures so that's gonna be coming in
an update very soon but for right now
we've got potted plants that we need to
fill with local soil before it becomes
night that's the first thing I'm gonna
do because on my food situation is gonna
be a little precarious here now I will
come clean I had to use some debug
commands to get enough material to be
able to build everything because good
god if I had to go out and farm
everything by hand to build that
precursor base just to be able to build
a goddamn castle on this island like Tom
Cruise in cast Oh nuttin I mean no III
mean Tom Cruise not Tom Hanks because
I'm going to be like - if it's because
if Tom Cruise was stuck alone on this
island I have a funny feeling he'd be
much crazier and much more like how I is
going to be while I am alone on this
island with no one by the name of Wilson
to keep me warm at night so anyway I'm
trying to go up I need to get some food
out of the potted plants and I know
there's one high up in this Observatory
here so that I'll be able to populate
mine and then I won't have to worry
about food so much that I will die
because dying is something that I'm very
good at at this game and I don't want to
be doing that while you guys are
watching I mean you guys have seen me
die all over the place like in every
other episode that I've done so I don't
know why this
would be much different I've already
opened you get out of the way please oh
come on get are you are you serious I'm
gonna be thwarted by a goddamn container
how the [ __ ] is this you serious here
move a that would thank you yeah
all right thank you very much okay oh
yeah I forgot I left it cooked hover
fish here that's no good okay so I'm
gonna get the hanging fruit just get a
bunch of those I don't think there's any
other fruit available there's the melon
plants that are in planters down below
but I don't know actually I forgot
there's no fall damage we Oh is there
fall damage whew there might be fall
damage no there's no fall damage for
some reason gravity's real low on this
island so now that I got these uh you'll
see that if I interact with these potted
plants over here actually I'm not 100%
this is how it works
cuz I've never done it before there's
all new territory for me but if I put
this whoops if I eat that Hey nice
that's gonna grow into a tree
eventually I mean not immediately now
but it's gonna do okay I suppose I
probably should have given it some more
room and maybe put some more sunlight
and maybe ready access to water and
maybe I should be more concerned about
the rest of the things that I've
murdered in my past because that's
probably gonna scare these things from
growing
but anyway so in these um various things
and this is where I use the console
commands I've got just a slew of
different types of building materials
gold diamond copper silver a lot of
titanium nothing in there just yet and
also some water and first-aid kits so
the only thing that I really need is
food and these are gonna take care of it
and when I find some goddamn melons on
this goddamn island everything is gonna
be okay so here we go the first step is
to build the foundation of my new castle
on this island I'm a little bit
perturbed about things but I'm gonna be
okay so I need a lot of titanium I need
quartz to be able to do this I'm gonna
get that much quartz I need some glass I
know that for a fact I probably need
some silicon I can't remember exactly
but it just it's a lot of titanium
that's gonna be so I'm just gonna fill
my inventory with titanium I can
okay so there's breaking new ground here
also these devices they make med kits
every 30 minutes so that's awfully
convenient so I just I'll never run out
of nevermind I just my inventory is full
they disappeared into the ether good I
don't get those great okay so that's a
good start to what I'm doing here the
other thing I'm going to do is I'm gonna
put the terraformer in my hotbar and I
figured out how to put things in my
hotbar and I'm gonna provide myself with
the perfect location with which to start
my Empire and it's gonna be up here
because I think it's a good perch I
don't I don't to build it all the way up
to the island although the the eventual
goal will be to make this connect to
that Observatory up there that's going
to be a [ __ ] to do I'm gonna be doing
this for a long time I'm gonna be using
doodles and oodles of console commands
but I'm gonna get it so here we go we're
the Frick am I going alright okay
alright right here right here is where I
lay the foundation to my glorious future
I don't know if this is gonna be able to
connect to anything else at all because
it seems to be in the wrong orientation
for one but that's not gonna stop me
when is being correct
ever gotten in my way huh oh good I
think that'll that'll dig out of the way
boink okay I did it hey first steps
first glorious steps I'm just gonna
build out a foundation around this thing
so that I have plenty of space with
which to build my Empire cuz god no wow
that is not that's that's not in line at
all there we go that's a little better
okay so now that we got the foundation
planted and we firmly decide we firmly
committed to this horrible atrocity that
I can't get up there
[ __ ] oh god damn it did I just I did I
walled myself off from being Oh poopy
butts well good thing I know how to get
rid of that okay I forgot that I could
just terraform this entire island and
get everything out of the way yeah well
there we go
bilder okay build it there we go this is
I guess
how goddamn it you stupid mushrooms get
out of my way okay
ah what have they done sure okay ah tits
okay all right
okay there we made it I've got my smooth
handicapped accessible ramp which is
regulation standard up to my goddamn
foundation and this goddamn foundation
is gonna sprawl to the empire that I'm
building everyone leave me alone I'm Tom
Cruise on an island it doesn't make a
lick of sense where where are you trying
to be where are you trying to be why
don't this just really really is that is
that the only thing that I can do here
really let's just let's just entertain
this thought right here let's entertain
this oh I've got some shade who needs a
tree when I've got a foundation over my
head that is sound science right there
huh all right Steph phase one completed
which is trying not to kill yourself so
I did that I'm not dead and hopefully
I'll be able to move forward from here
with goodness and graciousness and
gracefulness okay so the entrance to the
castle is slightly compromised and
there's there's a few trees that are
gonna be intersecting inside my goddamn
castle but at least my goddamn castle is
goddamn standing that's all that matters
whew there we go sorry burped link there
and then we go inside yeah it's got some
natural lived-in fauna look to it I like
the vines that are already creeping into
my life
let's just get some glass so that we can
observe all the wonderful wonderful miss
that is our view oh look at that I can
almost see the sunset through a few
leaves oh there's a bit of sky isn't
that wonderful I'm doing great I'm out
of glass good thing I know my
fabricators over there holy [ __ ] I have
made some Grievous errors if things went
so much better
ignore that turd monster over there
things went so much better when I was
trying to
bilbies while I was able to think to
myself exactly what I'm doing but ever
it's fine
just it's totally fine no one needs to
work
look at them they're growing isn't that
delightful okay so we got those
everything's fine
we got potted plants a growing like
crazy we we got materials out the wazoo
and so now I need to go back to my
goddamn Island that's so goddamn easy to
get sooo bubble butt Island is being a
bit more of a pain in the butt than I
thought it would be alright hang on I
got it I'm sure wish I could see things
oh I know I can build lights oh I can do
that because I got power I can do that
not that I don't need a comfy chair I
mean I would love a comfy chair at the
moment but I don't need a comfy chair
okay so if I build this right here yeah
how do we turn on Oh what the hell where
you going
it's a spotlight oh okay that's that's
not horribly what are you doing that's
not at all horribly useful I don't see
how that's gonna help me in any way our
hand what oh I stopped its coat of light
I feel like I did something horribly
wrong okay so let's try this again a
little little better hopefully all right
try this yeah yeah yeah not creepy at
all I thought it would've been better on
land but apparently you were just gonna
be terrified no matter where we were are
you doing there what are you doing what
are you doing what are you doing are you
okay it's still alive oh man things are
going so horribly wrong for me okay yep
there's wait a bit a lot but it's almost
as if these buildings are meant to be
made under water and not over water
because over water isn't actually a term
that people use and I'm just an idiot
Hey
Dada Dada Dada Dada is that good I don't
know if that's good does that help me
does that help anybody it certainly
doesn't help me
oh it's do
I have left two titanium enough for one
more oh hello handsome how are you doing
huh da [ __ ] huh - [ __ ] well can't be
that well can't do that either
hot tits I have oh hello how you doing
that's where you went - whoa this this
episode is going after the horse start
the hi ever thought okay alright so now
that is starting to turn in today least
I hope it is because if it's not holy
[ __ ] this is what is you anyway why are
you glowing red uh it's kind of cool but
kind of terrifying at the same time okay
so we've made exactly one unit of
progress getting this castle and if you
if you guys can go buy anything of me
building this then you can judge how
long it took me to build the goddamn
like staging area before I was gonna
build the castle but I'm gonna be old
and it's good it's gonna be nuts because
I gotta get above it and that's the only
problem getting above it is a bit hard
because I want to place this up there
but for some reason the game don't let
me do that very easily because it almost
as if it anticipated that I was swimming
in the water and able to build above
very hard man
okay cool beans going for it [ __ ] okay
good enough good enough good enough
there we go we have two storey building
I want to get one more story in there
but I barely have enough stories as it
is why can't I place that rise
why why why sir ma'am why is that not
acceptable placement it's a perfectly
good room
oh you're [ __ ] with me now oh you're
digging with me we're gonna have hatches
going every which away cuz I'm just I
just need to get in there I just I got
damnit
hello goodbye okay there we go now that
is a tower it's a parapet and I don't
know what a parapet is but I know that
castles have a lot of them and they talk
about them all the time that's all that
I've ever heard from ancient history is
about how big their parapets were so I
made the biggest parapet because I'm the
best so I just need to make ladders in
between each one because I'm not stupid
I mean I've I am of course very stupid
in everything that I'm doing in this
game but in this particular moment I'm
not stupid yeah okay so damn oh we need
to get more titanium uh everybody
riveted boink okay so now that we got
enough and we get the lights all going
and we get the power going and I need to
get more solar panels because those
lights are drones energy does sorry god
dammit of grooves don't worry I'm just
casting okay boink there's another one
boink there's no one okay we're doing
good we got these in here we're almost
to the top almost to the top floor and
once we get up there I'm actually gonna
put windows all around the sides so that
we can see everything in the nearby
countryside we can see the entirety of
our kingdom so that we know what we have
to look forward to and we have to look
forward to a lot because there's a lot
in our future we are conquerors we are
literally alone on this island forever
and ever inand no one's here to help us
and excuse me I'm just gonna because I I
don't have enough I don't want to go all
the way back down to get more glass just
so I can finish this out I want to
finish this out so I can finish this
episode and tell you guys there I
haven't begun the project with which
will consume my life and in the next
episode I'll be a bit farther along in
my castle and out something more to show
you and then hopefully there's gonna be
even more updates throughout the game
but you can see just about everything
from here all the way to the aurora to
the mysterious nod island which i think
you can see it out of the left
that little line there may be it I have
no idea but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching sub
Nautica will continue we've got a lot
more stuff in store for you so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
then blender but for now whatever
don't look at my electric it you're
[ __ ] electric it line up at that
place game and I want to get in fingers
are creepy I'm not creepy I swear